are you the guy who got Travolta to
shave his head
are you the guy I didn't get him to
shave his head but he asked me if he
could shave his head and I said why not
absolutely I think Travolta looks great
now you had a private conversation and
you said so he came to we were doing the
Chinese Theater in Los Angeles and I was
putting my hands in the cement things
that nature he came out to speak on my
behalf really what an honor right having
one of the biggest best actors in
Hollywood history to come out and that's
what he asked me at and he's like hey
what do you think about this
why not right and sure enough man he
cracked it and I agree now I know what
I'm gonna look like when I get older you
put him in one of your videos and uh he
dances oh yeah yeah I mean getting
Travolta to do that that's a trip that's
a big deal yeah he's a trip and it's
I love to sit with him and just have
conversations of everything that he's
been through in life it's amazing advice
but half of you know not not half of it
I would say like 99 of you like this is
unbelievable but it's happened so it's
not like someone's just talking to
you right so that's what makes it so I
would say powerful and Priceless to be
able to hang out and and shoot the
with uh Travolta
foreign